with sixty thousand dollars make the
very long retirement So based off of
amount of Landing
really you're cold
[Music]
around me
memories
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
swirling songs
it's coming off
secret stuff right here
get at any Home Depot
as I'm sorting through this footage I'm
on a boat
in Norway
it's windy
stormy
and we're currently crossing the North
Sea
I have so many stories I want to share
so much I want to show you I don't even
know where to begin
part of me wants to focus on this
adventure I'm currently on and skip over
all the many months that came before it
but there are some changes happening
right now that might not make sense if I
hit fast forward
so let's begin where we last left off
the Southwest desert
and then West
to the California coast
[Music]
foreign
everything is off-grid also check out
this pocket door full-length mirror and
the thing is that's just comes into us
how pretty that is like you do a full
build and then you do again the second
time you have it in retro appliances
yeah pretty neat it's really hard to do
it without
without messing up the first time kind
of yeah yeah so washer dryer so that's
All Storage under the bed yeah and it
just stays up and then
what's so cool and then these steps have
storage in them too
so creative I'm gonna go back and forth
like oh does the
kitchen go here or should it be like
here and you get to play around with all
of those beforehand everything is solar
powered here
off these goals are all solar panels
there's even there's a shed in the back
outdoor shower
and then Travis has this sick rig to go
out on adventures
uh four wheel camper
pretty cool these gas tanks in the back
max track shovel
a little awning this would be so cool
4x4 to get just about anywhere
back on the road
tide is really low it's getting it's
still dropping I think a little too
[Music]
it's been months since I've filmed these
moments like I've said so many times
before I struggle to keep up
at least one thing is current
I'm by the Sea again
but more accurately in it
a week has passed since I began this
edit and now I'm sailing from Scotland
to London
if you're confused it's not just you I
usually am too
if it weren't for picking up my camera
every now and then I swear I would
forget half the things I've done most of
the places I've been and the incredible
people I've met
I just don't think it's possible to be
fully present if you're always looking
back at the past
or wishing for the future
but in this moment floating out to sea
and reflecting on the month or so I
spent roaming the California coast
earlier this year
I can see now that it was a turning
point for me
it was a change I really needed
a time in which I quit marooning myself
and the desolation of the desert and
spending all my time going inward
I found myself happy both being with
friends and also just being alone
a kind of balance emerged without any
real sense of effort
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
very old
wherever you've been
I'll follow you around every
follow you into
calm down
back of falling Stone
colors blue
memories fade
what we found is to stay
[Music]
the story through
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I spent a couple weeks pet sitting in
Santa Monica
and the house I stayed in was honestly
too pretty for words
The Greenery the light the quiet
it felt like a hitting Garden of Eden
it was everything I needed
and then
I was back on the road
over the past few months a handful of
things have gone wrong with the van
like really wrong
we'll get to it
I've had to shift my summer plans and
tomorrow morning when I step off this
boat I'll be flying into the unknown
but truthfully
I'm okay with it
it'll be okay if things work out and
it'll be fine if they don't
also side note
I kind of want to move to Norway
maybe someday
whatever happens
we'll find out together
thanks for being here
and I'll see you in the next one
oh it's cool